You and I share something in common.
We're both very beautiful and very tall.
Yeah.
(audience cheering and applauding)
We hit it off.
I remember when we first met, we hit it off.
It was just...
I mean potentially related, hopefully married.
(Conan and audience laughing)
I have to make one phone call to get this done.
Yeah, okay.
I'm ready, I'm waiting.
I am there.
But what I've noticed is that there are so many,
women can sort of put a hat down and not be noticed,
but you're very striking, you're very tall.
You don't blend in.
Yeah, not me.
I'm not blending anytime soon.
I mean and I often think in kind of the most mundane
situations, of course no one would ever recognize me.
I went to the dentist.
I was having a horrific root canal.
The dentist, he went through it.
I was traumatized, he left the room.
The dental nurse was there.
The clamp was in my mouth.
She was peering in.
And I was there sort of gripping,
and I thought she was about to offer me some soothing words
and instead I get,
"Tell me what happens in Game of Thrones!"
(laughing)
While I'm there prostrating, tortured.
So there's a lot of boons to this job.
There's a lot of (snapping) plus points.
[Conan] Right.
Torture in dental chair.
(laughing)